am Lena the plug I am an adult Creator
my name is Adam 22 and I co-own plug
talk with my lovely wife we interview a
different girl every week and then we
them at the end but we've only ever done
it with other women so we've arranged
this whole challenge to find the perfect
guy to be our first ever boy boy girl 3
let me get in the room with her
about how Brave of her oh you're against
this because you're jealous cuz you
don't have a woman is hot it's like yeah
neither does Adam 22 I've never met
somebody in their 50s that was like hey
this is my wife Martha and uh the guy
she's been banging for 5 years exactly
we are so happy well she's namely happy
with other people uh and I'm happy in
the corner that's why I give her a
$400,000 Lambo every time she courts uh
a black pornography actor are you so
insecure you wouldn't let your wife have
sex with as many strangers as she wants
I I guess so yep